All right. There we go, so I screwed up the even-odd test.
Okay, so xmod2=1, that is to say if we had an odd numbered run through our outer testing loop,
we're going to bias the probability towards removing from the queue.
Otherwise, we're going to bias towards adding to a queue. Okay, good.
This time, we added to a non-full queue 600,000 times
added to a full queue almost 400,000 times removed from a non-empty queue 600,000 times
and removed from an empty queue close to 400,000 times.
This time, even with 1,000 element queue, by adding this bouncing back and forth behavior,
we managed to do a good random testing.
If you think about it, this idea of adding a new outer testing loop
to a random tester is often a pretty good one.
If you think about it, that's exactly probably
what we would end up doing from the file system example.
For special case, mount and unmount, probably what that's going to mean is
hard coating are call to mount at the start of a random file system test,
then executing a bunch of API calls, that is to say opens, closes, make directories and stuff,
and at the end, we're going to hard coat and unmount call.
What that fails to do is interesting stress testing of the mount and unmount logic,
and so remember, if we call mount and unmount with equal probability
as the rest of the calls that was too many times.
But if we hard coat a call to those at the beginning and end of our entire
random testing run, that's probably too few.
What we can do is mount the file system, do a bunch of stuff, unmount it,
and then enclose that in an outer testing loop to make sure that we sort of stress
all the parts of the system that we intend to stress.
We can imagine that the state machine from the file system case is considerably more complicated
than the state machine for queue,
but on the other hand, we could still do this diagram or something like it
and we find that we need to adjust our probabilities.
This is a sort of a deep topic and it's a difficult one. Let's take at one more example.